About 200 years ago from now
, a cataclysmic fire disaster occurred, posh, and the earth was engulfed in a sea of ​​fire.
Many continents were burned to the ground.
A human body ignited, and the
surviving humans were
forced to live in fear of the sudden
appearance of flame people
.
To save Chinkonshi alone and the soul of the flame man, and to
save humanity from the horror of the great flames as quickly as possible is
our guard
[Music] I have
great expectations,
freely light the flames
There's no such thing as that  I'm from the second generation, so I need a fire starter to start a fire, and
25 Show me a movie that
doesn't exist.
Let's quickly stop this phenomenon of human combustion takigen
[music] The
dedication is fun Cutting the stalk
Black smoke is the release of the soul
[music]
The flames of yellow seize
Applause]
Devil's footprints
?  About how your mother and brother died
That day when you became a demon
This is a soul-looking
black smoke is the liberation of the soul
[music]